Speaker 1: I really can't believe this is where
the country is right now, but 30 percent of
Republicans, three in 10 Republicans now believe
that Donald Trump is going to be reinstated as
president sometime in twenty twenty one. What the
hell is wrong with this country? How are so many
people this disconnected from reality? Is anybody
else realizing how much of a red alert disaster
it is that this many Americans are so ignorant
to think that this is even remotely possible?
Now, before we get to the poll numbers. Let
me give you a little bit of context. Over
the last couple of weeks, The New York Times, The
Washington Post, The National Review have reported
that Donald Trump believes and is telling
people that he will be reinstated as president
around August. Now, when initially some people
reacted and said, no, no, that's fake news.
The right wing National Review came out
and said, not only does Trump believe that
there are multiple Republican senators who believe
that David Perdue believes he'll be reinstated,
Martha McSally believes she's going to be
reinstated. This is impossible. There is no
reinstatement mechanism. We have a president. We
have a line of succession. The president would
be replaced by the vice president. If anything
happens, then comes the speaker of the House.
For now, Trump is neither. I know earlier this
week, we talked about the possibility Trump
would run for Congress and then try to become
speaker of the House. But for now, Trump is not
a former president, is not part of the line of
succession. So one side of this is that Donald
Trump is starting to sort of lay the groundwork
for a violent coup attempt. That's one side of it.
But the other side is the people who believe,
hey, they might just confirm the voter fraud
and then Trump's back in power. They might
reinstate Donald Trump. And it turns out that
30 percent of Republicans believe Donald Trump
will be reinstated in this calendar year. This
is from a new Politico morning consult poll from
yesterday which found that most Americans realize,
of course, Trump won't be reinstated. But
29 percent of Republicans do think Trump
will end up somehow being president again this
year. Almost just as shocking, quite frankly,
is that 16 percent of Democrats believe
the same thing. 16 percent of Democrats
also believe Donald Trump might be reinstated
or will be reinstated as president this year.
Please call in. I don't care if you're a Democrat
or a Republican or an independent if you believe
Donald Trump is going to be reinstated this year.
Please call into the show next week. I want to
hear from you. Please explain to me the mechanism
by which Donald Trump would again be president
before the end of the year. How would it happen?
This is essentially as unlikely as Jesus appears
by August. They're essentially equally likely. And
a question that's never answered when you ask them
is by what mechanism or legal authority will
Donald Trump be reinstated? What precedent
would allow something like this to happen? And
this is how we get back to the coup idea, because
there is no such mechanism. There is no such
president precedent short of a violent revolution
of some kind, which probably requires the backing
of the really the majority of the military
to remove Joe Biden. There is no way that this
could happen. And that's why we keep thinking.
Are they thinking of some kind of violent coup?
The other aspect about the 30 percent that believe
that Donald Trump is going to be reinstated
is that 30 percent are willing to admit it.
And that's something else we have to think
about. There could be another chunk of the
electorate that believes Donald Trump is going to
be reinstated this year, but has the sense not to
admit it when they're called by a pollster. That's
a possibility for sure. So a substitute headline
would be 30 percent of Republicans willing
to admit they believe Donald Trump will be
reinstated. And then another substitute headline
would be 30 percent of Republicans believe
anything that comes out of Donald Trump's
mouth period, no matter how absurd it is
if you go to them in September. And, of
course, Trump won't be president and you say
what happened? Explain what happened.
They will come up with some excuse.
And if 30 percent believe this, then Donald
Trump surely could get reelected in 2024
because they still love him and they've
learned nothing from the disaster
that was the last four years of Donald Trump.
This is really scary stuff. And it's sort of like
best case and worst case. Worst case, these people
are just dumb and they don't understand Trump
being reinstated is impossible. Worst case, they
understand the idea. Reinstatement as code that
they should do some kind of violent coup attempt
and we're going to see real violence coming coming
up in the end of summer. The best case isn't good,
but the worst case is really significantly worse.